tarik and i met each other a million
years ago at a theater in amsterdam
called boom chicago we used to work
there and at that theater we used to
play an improv game called name that
tune
it is my favorite improv game and i know
we do not do improv on this show but
today our show's musical director dr
david schmoll is in town
yeah so
anytime you hear a song on this show it
was composed by that guy yeah because
schmoll is here and because all of you
are here we thought we would do a teensy
bit of improv is that okay
okay
all right so
uh we're gonna play a guessing game and
it has to be pointed out that we are not
cheating i will not be able to hear your
suggestions and no one will tell me nope
we are not cheating this is improv not
magic okay okay do you understand that
there's no cheating there's no cheating
okay okay please do not come up to us
after talking about did you cheat no no
i mean no all right
okay so let's get started all right
okay to play this first improv game the
number one thing we have to do is send
tarik davis out of the room so on the
count of three everyone say goodbye
tarik one two three
there he goes everybody to the amber
ruffin show soundproof booth otherwise
known as the kitchen
and even though it's full of margaritas
he'll probably eat a carrot okay he is
gone now i would like you to shout out a
sentence any sentence at all like the
turtle had a sad birthday or those pants
are for window washers or
stop way in the back this lady voice
don't move to florida
move to
don't move to florida great don't move
to florida that's great what did i hear
down here
i suck my thumb great
uh let's just put can we just put those
two together great the sentence we have
is don't move to florida
because i suck my thumb now that
sentence makes no sense and it's going
to be very difficult for tarik to get uh
don't move to florida because i suck my
thumb now at one point i will forget and
jenny i want you to give me like some
kind of clue okay when tara comes back
he and i are going to sing a song and
the title of that song is going to be
don't move to florida because i suck my
thumb now tarik does not know that so
i'm going to give him clues while we're
singing but i'm not allowed to say any
of the actual words so there are a few
ways you can help him out whenever he
gets close we can all go together ooh
let's try that ooh that's right you
don't need to do the hands but they help
and when he gets it right i want you to
explode into uproarious applause which
sounds like this
yay
and lastly please do not shout out the
answer i know it seems obvious but we've
had trouble in the past that's why we no
longer allow belgians in our theater
now i understand that doesn't make a lot
of sense but in amsterdam dutch people
love that joke okay so the sentence is
don't move to florida because i suck my
thumb great we're gonna put it at the
bottom of the screen to help you guys
remember but taric will not be able to
see it it's not on this monitor it's not
back there and we will not be
shouting it out great but on the count
of three we will be shouting come back t
watch me come back t
now somebody go get him
all right all the way from new jersey
it's tearing touchdown dennis hey
all right tarek did you hear what we
said while you were in the kitchen no no
did you eat up all the carrots yes okay
ladies and gentlemen may we present the
smooth r and b stylings of tarik
and amber
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there is kind of like a universal sign
for no it's like a red line
with a line through it
and it tells you
how you should behave
whether you should or should not do a
thing so that sign kind of means stop
or it kind of means
no kind of kind of means
okay let's take a different route baby
my favorite drink is that yellow green
juice
that it's uh oh
mountain mountain dude okay
but
uh don't that's right
don't stop okay
uh years ago you and i used to live in
amsterdam
amsterdam and now you live in new jersey
actually brooklyn
so what did you do to get from there to
there what do you call that
i commuted no
i took the train you packed up all of
your [ __ ] oh i moved yeah
so what you got so far
i got don't move that's right
don't stop don't go just don't move but
i really gotta say i'm in the crew i
really don't know how to stop moving all
right
let me uh uh give you a little counting
one
three
four
five what's missing
i didn't hear two yes right
what you got
in here too
i didn't hear it too so i don't move
two
now where do you naturally think you
shouldn't move to just if you just had
to guess randomly
mar-a-lago
where is that
where is mar-a-lago
where is it it's on a golf course hey
where's that that's the golf course yes
on donald trump's property yes where is
our property properties in florida
[Applause]
here we go
one more time it was said now don't move
to florida that's right
but there is more to this
sentence i'm sorry
now you just said
why
why and if you were gonna start the
answer to that you would use the word
because
all right
don't do that don't do it so don't
move
to florida
because you're black
no that's not true but
that is just good advice yes that's just
good advice if you're black stay up here
please okay you black okay so
uh-huh you got that don't move to
florida because
hi yes
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
okay
uh-huh yeah um this is
a really kind of gross thing to say let
me think of a clean way oh babies whoa
when babies have a bottle and they put
it in their mouth and you say
um damn that's cute
oh
how did they get the milk out of that
bottle into their mouths
they slurped it god damn it terry
[Applause]
shut up
okay
uh-huh the thing that is
doesn't belong
uh
to me it belongs to you
so it is
it's mine yes
it's not your pinky your ring finger or
your index finger
what do you suck
my
my thumb yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
don't move to florida that's right don't
move to florida cause ah yes cause i
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you